A la fin du 19e siècle,
les Mathématiques se retrouvent dans un état
chaotique.
De nombreux théorèmes
y compris les théorème de Pytagorre
D'Euler
ou de Cauchy
ont été démontrés faux
tandis que les monstres de Fourrier
Weierstrass
et Cantor
ont anéanti l'image d'un monde platonicien,
simple, élégant et idéal.
Pire encore :
Même la géométrie d'Euclide
qui servait de modèle de rigueur
et de vérité indiscutable
était mise à mal par
La géométrie n'offrant plus
les garanties qu'elle semblait devoir garantir,
Gauss, qui considérait que les Mathématiques était
la reine des sciences,
affirma que la reine des Mathématiques
était, du coup, l'arithmétique
(l'étude des nombres).
Si les courbes et les droites ne sont pas forcément ce que l'on croit qu'elles sont,
Surement les nombres, eux, ne peuvent pas nous trahir.
En particulier, l'équation 1+1=2
semble être, elle, une vérité indiscutablement vraie.
Mais cela n'a rien de si évident que cela.
Enfait, en 1910,
les logiciens Bertrand Russell et Alfred North Whithead
ont écrit tout un livre
(le Principia Mathematica)
qui cherchait à poser les fondement des Mathématiques
et dans ce livre, il leur aura fallu 379 pages
pour prouver que 1+1=2.
379 pages pour prouver que 1+1=2 !!!
Et encore, ça c'est si vous croyez en la logique de Russel et Whitehead.
Le problème de base de l'équation 1+1=2,
c'est que, contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait croire,
l'équation n'est en fait pas si bien définie.
A priori, on sait tous ce que ces symboles veulent dire,
mais qu'est ce que ça veut vraiment dire ?
Qu'est-ce que le 1 ?
Qu'est-ce que le 2 ?
Qu'est ce que ce + ?
Et surtout,
Qu'est-ce que ce symbole d'égalité ?
Je suis sur que vous pensez connaitre les définitions de ces symboles,
Mais je suis à peu près, également aussi sur
que vous ne les connaissez pas vraiment.
Notamment parce que ces symboles, en fait,
ont des définitions différentes
selon les théories dans lesquelles on se place.
Aujourd'hui on va parler de l'une des meilleures façon de définir les symboles de cette équation
qui a été proposée par le mathématicien italien Giuseppe Peano
dont on a déjà parlé dans l'épisode 10.
Et pourtant,
on va voir que même la réponse de Peano
est loin d'être pleinement satisfaisante.
Alors, il est important, pour un logicien en tout cas,
de distinguer les axiomes de Peano des axiomes de l'arithmétique de Peano.
Aujourd'hui on va parler de l'arithmétique de Peano et pas des axiomes de Peano.
Pour en savoir plus sur les axiomes de Peano, je vous invite à aller voir cette superbe vidéo de Passe-Science.
L'arithmétique de Peano et certes plus faible que les axiomes de Peano,
mais elle est aussi plus directement adaptée
à faire de l'arithmétique, c'est à dire
à étudier les opérations entre les nombres dont on a l'habitude.
Et avant toute chose,
pour vraiment comprendre, notamment la distinction entre les axiomes de Peano
et l'arithmétique de Peano,
il faut bien voir,
et ce sera très important, notamment lorsqu'on parlera du théorème d'incomplétude de Gödel,
que dans l'arithmétique de Peano,
on a le droit qu'à un nombre fini de symboles.
En particulier, les symboles 1 et 2 de l'équation 1+1=2
sont en fait interdits
en arithmétique de Peano.
Mais bon, enfin, si vous les mettez,
on va pas vous couper un bras parce que vous avez écrit 1 ou 2
dans des équations de l'arithmétique de Peano.
Mais techniquement, les symboles que l'on a le droit d'utiliser
sont uniquement le 0,
le signe =,
le signe +,
le x qui désigne la multiplication,
le S, les parenthèses,
la flèche de gauche à droite,
un espèce de v,
un espèce de v inversé
une marche d'escalier,
un A majuscule renversé verticalement,
et un E majuscule renversé horizontalement.
Techniquement, en arithmétique de Peano,
vous n'avez le droit d'utiliser que ces symboles.
Alors, vous avez sans doute une petite idée de ce que peuvent vouloir dire les trois premiers symboles.
Qu'en est-il du S ?
Le S est en fait l'opérateur de succession.
Ainsi, lorsque j'écris S0,
en fait, je fais référence au nombre entier naturel qui vient juste après 0.
Du coup S0, en fait, ça va être 1.
Et de la même façon, SS0
ça va être celui qui vient juste après S0,
qui était 1,
donc SS0, en gros, ca représente le 2
auquel on est habitué.
Et du coup, l'équation 1+1=2, en fait,
elle se réécrit, en arithmétique de Peano,
S0+S0=SS0.
Les parenthèses sont, bien entendu, là pour clarifier la manière dont ce combinent les différentes opérations.
Enfin, il reste encore les symboles flèche vers la droite,
v, v renversé,
marche d'escalier,
A renversé et
le E renversé.
Ces symboles sont des connecteurs logique,
ou plutôt, ces symboles ont des interprétations en termes de connecteurs logique.
La flèche est une implication logique;
le v est un "ou";
le v renversé est un "et"
la marche d'escalier est un "non";
le A renversé se lit "pour tout";
et le E renversé se lit "il existe".
Enfin, dernière chose : on va avoir des variables qui représentent les objets de l'arithmétique de Peano.
Il est courant d’appeler les objets de l'arithmétique de Peano
des nombres entiers naturels.
Et intuitivement, l'arithmétique de Peano ne peut parler que des nombres entiers naturels,
contrairement aux axiomes de Peano qui, eux, sont capables de parler d'ensembles d'entiers naturels.
Mais passons à des exemples, ça va vous aidez à mieux comprendre les symboles de l'arithmétique de Peano.
Prenons par exemple cet exemple là :
Si on traduit littéralement, il dit
que si je prends n'importe quel objet X de l'arithmétique de Peano,
il est faux de dire que le successeur de X est égal à 0.
En français moins alambiqué, ça veut dire que 0 n'a pas de prédécesseur.
Il n'y a rien qui vient avant 0. Il n'y a aucun nombre entier naturel avant 0.
Cette phrase est d’ailleurs le premier axiome de l'arithmétique de Peano.
C'est à dire qu'on a pas à le prouver,
qu'on va juste le supposer vrai,
comme étant un des fondements, un des points de départ
de la logique de l'arithmétique de Peano.
Voyons maintenant si vous arrivez à comprendre le deuxième axiome de l'arithmétique de Peano.
Alors, qu'est-ce que ça peut bien vouloir dire
que ces symboles de l'arithmétique de Peano ?
Et bien, si je traduis littéralement, ça veut dire
que pour tout objet X
de l'arithmétique de Peano,
il existe un objet Y
de l'arithmétique de Peano
tel que
si X n'est pas égal à 0,
alors, le successeur de Y est égal à X.
En français plus facile à comprendre,
cette phrase revient à dire
que tout nombre entier naturel non nul est le successeur d'un nombre entier naturel.
Je vais passer plus vite sur les autres axiomes de l'arithmétique de Peano.
Mais n'hésitez pas à mettre pause et prendre le temps de bien comprendre ces axiomes.
Le troisième dit que si deux nombres ont le même successeur,
alors ils sont égaux.
Le quatrième dit qu'un nombre plus 0
ne modifie pas la valeur de ce nombre.
Le cinquième dit que X plus le successeur de Y
est égal au successeur de X+Y.
Le sixième dit que X fois 0 est égal à 0.
Et le septième dit que X fois le successeur de Y
est égal à X fois Y
plus X.
Maintenant que l'on a nos axiomes, on va pouvoir prouver que 1+1=2.
Alors, vous voyez comment faire ?
On va partir de l'axiome 5.
Il dit que S0 plus S0
est égale à S de S0+0.
Ensuite on va utiliser l'axiome 4
qui dit que S0 plus 0 est égal à S0.
Et du coup, S de S0+0 est égal
à S(S0).
Mais, à partir de ces deux égalités,
est-ce que l'on peut vraiment conclure
que S0+S0 est égal à S(S0) ?
Pas vraiment ...
En fait, il nous manque des axiomes.
Il nous manque même tout plein d'axiomes qui ont été cachés dans les opérations de notre "preuve"
de 1+1=2.
Il s'agit des axiomes de la Logique.
On trouve ainsi, par exemple,
le fait que la négation d'un "pour tout X, P(X)"
est "il existe X tel que nonP(X)".
Il y a aussi des axiomes spécifiques à l'égalité
comme par exemple, si X est égal à Y
et Y est égal à Z,
alors X est égal à Z.
C'est ce qu'on appelle la transitivité de l'égalité
et il s'agit d'un axiome de la logique.
Les axiomes de Peano viennent donc en complément des axiomes de la logique.
Et ça, ça nous permet de définir
le symbole = (plus ou moins).
En fait, le symbole = c'est quoi ?
C'est un symbole que l'on a le droit de manipuler
selon les règles définies par les axiomes de la logique et de l'arithmétique de Peano.
C'est bizarre, hein ?
Mais si on prend le formalisme de Peano au pied de la lettre,
il n'y a vraiment que ça, il n'y a vraiment qu'un jeu
de manipulation de symboles : pas de vérités mathématiques sous-jacentes.
Bref. On avait prouvé S0+S0=S(S0+0).
Et on avait prouvé que S(S0+0)=S(S0).
On peut maintenant conclure en utilisant la transitivité de l'égalité
qui nous dit que de ces deux égalités, on peut déduire le fait
que S0+S0 est égal à S(S0).
Ca y est !!! On a prouvé que 1+1=2.
Bon, on a pas été ultra rigoureux
mais ...
pas loin, pas loin, pas loin.
Il nous reste un huitième axiome dans l'arithmétique de Peano
qui est, de loin, le plus sophistiqué de tous les axiomes.
C'est même un schéma d'axiomes de récurrence,
ce qui veut dire que c'est une infinité d'axiomes :
un pour chaque formule phi qu'on arrive à écrire
dans le langage de l'arithmétique de Peano
où phi peut potentiellement dépendre
de n+1 variables.
Ce schéma d'axiomes de récursion nous dit
que si on a réussi à prouver
phi de 0, X1 jusqu'à Xn,
(ça c'est ce que l'on appelle l'initialisation)
et si on a réussi a prouver l'implication
phi de X, X1 jusqu'à Xn
implique phi de S de X, X1 jusqu'à Xn,
(ça c'est ce qu'on appelle l'hérédité)
alors, par l'axiome de récurrence appliqué à la formule phi,
on peut déduire de tout cela, que phi de X0, X1 jusqu'à Xn
est toujours vrai.
Alors ce huitième axiome, je vous l'accorde, est beaucoup plus compliqué que tous les autres.
Mais c'est aussi le plus magique de tous les axiomes.
Grace à cet axiome, par exemple,
on peut prouver que X+Y est toujours égal à Y+X.
Et je vous propose dans les commentaires
d'essayer d'écrire uniquement dans le langage de l'arithmétique de Peano
le fait qu'il existe un nombre infini de nombres premiers.
Et vous pouvez utiliser ce site
pour vous aider à écrire les symboles de l'arithmétique de Peano.
Alors, il est pas trop dur de se convaincre du fait
que les axiomes de l'arithmétique de Peano
sont "vrais"
pour les nombres entiers naturels
tels qu'on les "pense" intuitivement.
Ce qui est plus difficile à savoir,
c'est : est-ce que les axiomes de l'arithmétique de Peano
sont suffisant
pour garantir que l'arithmétique de Peano
parle bien uniquement des nombres entiers naturels
tels qu'on les connait.
Eh bien la réponse est non.
En particulier, on a envie de dire
que tout nombre entier naturel
s’obtient en appliquant suffisamment de fois
l'opérateur de succession
au nombre 0.
Et bien ça, on peut pas le prouver
il est même concevable qu'il puisse exister
des nombres dits "non standards"
qui vivraient sur une branche parallèle
à la branche des nombres entiers naturels que l'on connait.
Il pourrait aussi très bien ne pas y avoir cette branche parallèle.
Ni l’existence, ni l'absence de cette branche parallèle
ne peut être déduite
des axiomes de l'arithmétique de Peano.
Mais du coup, on pourrait être tenté de se demander :
est-ce qu'il pourrait y avoir
un neuvième axiome à ajouter
à l'arithmétique de Peano
pour exclure l'existence
de cette branche parallèle de nombres non standards.
Eh bien, je vous invite à proposer un tel neuvième axiome
de l'arithmétique de Peano
dans les commentaires. Et je reviendrai sur vos commentaires dans le prochain épisode.
La dernière fois on a parlé des fractions, et on a vu
qu'elles étaient à la fois partout
dans le sens où elles étaient denses
dans l'ensemble des nombres réels, mais aussi
nul part dans le sens où ça forme un ensemble de mesures nules
Et en particulier, on avait prouvé
ça en recouvrant avec des bouts de tissu
tous les nombres rationnels entre zéro et un.
Segror Mandon nous demande si on a recouvert tous les rationnels une infinité de fois
quels sont les nombres qui n'ont pas été recouverts par aucun bout de tissu
dans ma construction.
Eh bien la réponse est : quasiment tous les nombres irrationnels.
Enfin en tout cas, une grosse partie des nombres irrationnels.
Plus exactement, je vous invite à essayer de vous convaincre vous-même
du fait que si je prends un nombre irrationnel au hasard
par exemple je prends racine carré de 2 divisé par 2
je sais qu'il est entre 0 et 1
alors je sais aussi à ce moment là
que si mon premier bout de tissu que je choisis
est suffisamment petit,
si au lieu de prendre un demi centimètre, je prends un demi nanomètre
ou un demi divisé par 10 puissance beaucoup
de mètres,
et bien, je saurai que à partir d'un beaucoup suffisamment grand,
la construction conduira au non recouvrement
de racine carré de 2 divisé par 2.
jihbed me suggère de faire un épisode hardcore
sur la théorie de la mesure.
Malheureusement j'ai pas trop le temps en ce moment
de me lancer dans un épisode hardcore
c'est beaucoup de travail.
Mais très rapidement, je peux vous dire
comment est-ce que
Lebesgue a réussi à repenser
complètement
l'intégrale.
L'intégrale c'était une somme infinie
pour la rendre
compatible avec des idées de mesures.
Pour illustrer ceci, on va prendre une pièce de 1€,
une pièce de 2€ et un billet de 5€.
Pour savoir quelle est la somme de ces deux pièces et de ce billet,
ce que l'on peut faire ... bon, on peut faire l'addition de base.
Mais si on est un peu plus tordu de la tête,
on peut vouloir d'abord compter le nombre de pièces qui font au moins 1€,
donc ça il y en a trois,
et ensuite compter le nombres de pièces qui valent au moins 2€,
ça il y en a deux,
puis compter le nombre de pièces qui font au moins 3€
ça il y en a plus qu'une,
puis compter le nombre de pièces qui font au moins 4€
ça il y en a une,
et compter le nombre de pièces qui font au moins 5€
ça il y en a une.
Et puis après, au delà,
si on regarde le nombre de pièces qui font au moins (ou de billets)
qui font au moins 6€
il y a plus rien.
Et là ce que je vais faire, c'est ajouter tous les nombres que j'ai obtenu
donc je vais faire 3+2+1+1+1
et magie magie:
je viens d'obtenir exactement le bon résultat.
Et bien l'intégrale de Lebesgue consiste à faire ça.
Donc si j'ai envie de trouver l'aire sous une courbe,
ce que je vais faire c'est considérer l'ensemble des points tels que la courbe est au dessus de 1,
je vais considérer la mesure de cet ensemble.
Puis je vais considérer l'ensemble des abscisses pour lesquelles la courbe est au dessus de 2,
et ainsi de suite.
Eh bien, si je fais cette construction,
bon de façon plus fine, au lieu d'aller de 1 en 1, je vais aller tout doucement quoi,
puis je vais prendre des histoires de limites encore une fois.
Mais si je fais ça bien, j'obtiens l'intégrale de Lebesgue
qui d'une certaine manière compte l'aire sous la courbe en ajoutant les couches successives
plutôt qu'en divisant de façon verticale comme le ferrait l'intégrale de Riemann.
Et du coup, ça, ça montre que pour calculer une intégrale, il suffit de savoir mesurer
des tailles d'ensembles.
Alors, ensuite, comment mesurer un ensemble,
il faut considérer un ensemble d'ensembles mesurables
qui doivent former une
enfin bon, avoir de bonnes propriétés,
notamment, l'union dénombrable
d'ensemble mesurable doit être un ensemble mesurable.
Et des trucs dans le genre.
Et une fois qu'on a ça, on peut définir des mesures, c'est-à-dire
des fonctions qui sont additives.
On veut que la mesure de deux ensembles disjoints
soit égale à la somme des mesures des deux ensembles.
Et ce qui est assez amusant, c'est que toute cette théorie de la mesure qui permet de calculer des intégrales
est en fait à la base de toute la théorie de la probabilité.
En fait, une probabilité c'est quoi ?
Quand on est dans le monde des maths pures.
Une probabilité, c'est une mesure
telle que la mesure de tout l'ensemble
donc de tous les événements possibles
est égale à 1.
Bon tout ce que je viens de raconter là c'est niveau au moins L3
donc si vous avez pas compris, c'est normal.
IlluzionnistFR nous demande
pourquoi est-ce que la probabilité de tirer un rationnel est égale à zéro,
sachant que
il propose une façon de tirer un nombre rationnel,
il suffit de prendre p aléatoirement et puis q aléatoirement
et puis on obtient p sur q.
Eh bien, ce qu'il faut bien voir, c'est qu'il y a différentes façons de définir de probabilités.
En fait, il n'existe pas de probabilité absolue,
il existe tout un tas de probabilités possibles,
qu'on peut considérer.
Celle que j'ai considérée dans l'épisode précédant,
c'est la probabilité qui est associée à la mesure de Lebesgue
puisque la mesure de l'ensemble [0,1]
dans le sens de Lebesgue
bah l'ensemble [0,1] il a une mesure égale à 1.
Du coup, s'il a une mesure totale égale à 1,
c'est que c'est une probabilité.
Et du coup, je peux tirer des trucs selon la mesure de Lebegues.
C'est ce que j'ai fait dans la vidéo précédante.
Ce que propose IlluzionnistFr,
c'est une autre mesure de probabilité,
c'est une autre probabilité, définie autrement.
Et je vous invite vraiment à aller voir le paradoxe de Bertrand.
Donc malheureusement, il y a que la page Wikipédia, il y a aucun youtuber qui a prit la peine d'en parler pour l'instant.
Elle montre très bien que
la notion de probabilité
est pas définie dans l'absolu
et qu'il y a en fait différentes façons
de définir une probabilité sur un ensemble donné.
VictorD nous demande
si le fait que la courbe de Hilbert soit de dimension 2
implique le fait qu'elle recouvre le plan.
Et la réponse à cette question est "non".
Et un exemple très amusant qui est l'exemple du mouvement Brownien
qui est une généralisation de la marche aléatoire dont nous a parlé mathémagique.
Tiens, je vais faire un petit peu de pub pour mathémagique :
c'est une très bonne vidéo
sur les marches aléatoires.
Le mouvement brownien qui est un mouvement dans le plan
est un fractale
et c'est même une fractale de dimension 2.
Mais elle ne recouvre pas tout le plan.
Elle ne passe pas par tous les points du plan.
Mais elle passe pas loin de tout point du plan.
Plus exactement, si vous prenez n'importe quel point du plan,
alors, vous pouvez montrer qu'avec une probabilité 1
le mouvement brownien
va passer une infinité de fois infiniment près
arbitrairement près plutot
du point que vous avez choisi.
Mais, avec une probabilité 1,
elle ne passera pas exactement par le point que vous avez choisi non plus.
Donc le mouvement brownien, c'est une courbe
qui va passer
arbitrairement près de tous les points du plan
mais qui ne va pas recouvrir le plan.
AlexSmg me demande
pourquoi est-ce que j'insiste sur le fait que
le fait que la mesure d'un point est égale à 0 n'est valable que dans "la théorie de Lebesgue".
Comme si la "théorie de Lebesgue" était encore à démontrer.
Il demande notamment "est-ce que la théorie de Lebesgue a été validé ?" .
Et c'est une question qui est
intéressante d'un point de vue épistémologique des Sciences. Comment on fait pour savoir les choses ?
Qu'est-ce que valider une théorie ?
En physique on peut plus ou moins "valider" des théories
avec des observations qui confirment encore et encore la théorie.
Mais en mathématiques, il n'y a absolument rien du genre.
Une théorie mathématique ne peut pas être validée.
Et ça c'est un truc qui est assez perturbant
quand on est pas habitué à cela.
Puisqu'on a l'impression que les Mathématiques c'est genre LA vérité
ou un truc indiscutablement vrai.
Bah j'espère que je vous ai montré notamment avec l'exemple de l'arithmétique de Peano
et on verra bien d'autres exemple dans les épisodes à venir
qu'il n'y a rien d'absolu en Mathématiques.
Tout dépend des axiomes que l'on a choisis.
Et certains axiomes sont plus ou moins populaires.
Des axiomes que les mathématiciens aiment bien accepter,
ou en tout cas prendre comme point de départ de leurs théories,
et d'autres axiomes
que les mathématiciens ignorent.
La théorie de Lebesgue, pour tous ceux qui font de l'analyse,
c'est un truc ultra accepté.
Donc on peut dire que c'est une théorie acceptée par la communauté mathématique
ou en tout cas une grosse partie de la communauté mathématiques.
En revanche, et je rebondis ainsi à la question de OrangeBleux,
la théorie des séries divergentes dont je vous ai parlé dans l'épisode 4
et 5 et notamment dans l'épisode hardcore
avec les super-sommations linéaires régulières et stables
ça correspond à des axiomes que beaucoup de mathématiciens
notamment à l'école
préfèrent ignorer.
Et c'est pour ça que j'insiste sur le fait qu'il ne faut pas faire ce que j'ai fait dans les épisodes 4 et 5
à l'école.
Puisque à l'école,
ce sont des axiomes
qu'on utilise qui ne sont pas communément acceptés
par les professeurs à l'école.
Et c'est vraiment pas grave que de rejeter certains axiomes.
Les axiomes n'ont rien de fondamentalement vrai.
Comme le dirait Henri Poincaré :
la géométrie n'est pas vraie,
elle est avantageuse dans certains cas
et parfois il vaut mieux prendre certains axiomes de la géométrie
et parfois il est plus pertinent d'utiliser d'autres axiomes de la géométrie.
En tout cas, c'est pas mal comme ça que je conçois les Mathématiques.
Mais on aura l'occasion de revenir bien plus en détail
sur ces notions de "véracité" en Mathématiques dans les prochains épisodes.
Hey, j'espère que vois avez aimé cet épisode. Maintenant que l'on a parlé de l'arithmétique de Peano,
on va pourvoir parler du théorème de Goodstein
qui est ultra perturbant,
notamment par rapport à cet arithmétique de Peano.
Si vous avez aimez cet épisode, pensez à le liker, à le commentez, à le partager,
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas manquer les futurs épisodes,
merci aux tippeurs pour leurs dons,
et j'espère que je vous verrai la prochaine fois.